what's up everybody my name is clinton
jones and i am excited to announce my
new
3d community challenge and this time
there's a twist so just last month i ran
an insane 3d community contest where i
challenged
cg artists of all skill levels to turn
this
into anything they could imagine 2400 of
you submitted to create two of the most
epic montages the internet has seen
the all renders montage and the top 100
montage
which i live judged with some very
special guests and to top it off the
best five entries
won insane prizes from companies whose
products i use
every day in my 3d workflow but today i
am thrilled to announce our third
3d community challenge i'm calling it
the dynamic machines
3d community render challenge and i'm
challenging you to guide a 3d
chrome ball from point a to point b and
you create
everything else in between simple as
that so i'll provide the 3d template
and you just worry about creating
something awesome this challenge is open
to all
3d artists at any skill level using any
program you have till august 1st 11 59
pm
pst and in the end i'll combine every
result
and together will form the internet's
longest
3d rube goldberg contraption it's going
to be sweet all right but look before we
get into the awesome prizes on behalf of
nvidia and p and y
let's talk about these challenge
requirements because the only way you're
going to be able to win prizes
and have your render scene in the final
montages is by following these specific
directions so your render must be 450
frames long that's frame 0 to frame
449 no more no less
you gotta drop a five centimeter chrome
ball with gravity into your contraption
be the starting point on frame 113
no sooner no later an identical
five centimeter chrome ball must
completely exit the contraption via the
exit port
between frames 335 and 340 again no
sooner
no later render a 1080 by 1920
resolution or higher animation do not
make the mistake of rendering a
1920x1080 render don't flip it around
your submission must be an mp4 video
file rendered in an h264 or h.265 codec
any other codec will run the risk of not
being seen and your render must be 30
frames per second not 29.97
not 24 exactly 30 frames per second
now let's talk about some camera
settings your shutter needs to be set to
1
over 180 for your motion blur settings
or that's
0.005556 no borders or harsh filters
that may degrade your render this
includes excessive chromatic aberration
excessive vignetting and excessive color
grading the camera is locked at a 50
millimeter focal length
do not change this the camera animation
is also preset do not touch this
and camera shake nah don't don't even
think about it
no on-screen titles your render simply
won't be accepted do not resize the
border of the play area
you may however decorate its appearance
and sound design is highly encouraged
now myself and my discord moderators
took a long time creating these
challenge rules
they need to be followed very
specifically in order to create a high
quality
seamless montage so if you all can
follow these directions
we can create the internet's largest 3d
contraption together
so let's talk prizes because nvidia and
pny are giving out three pieces of
hardware
to the top three us artists
international artists don't worry i got
you guys for third place pny is hooking
you up with a 500 gig
2.5 inch sata 3 ssd
this is an easy upgrade from your
standard hard drive and ensures your
computer and programs boot up a lot
faster
second place is getting a one terabyte
m2 nvme ssd meaning you'll boot and open
apps with read write speeds up to six
and a half
gigs that's pretty darn fast and finally
if your machine is the best out of all
the other machines
then you're getting an nvidia quadro rtx
5000 quadro series cards have helped me
take my renders to the next level
and i know they will for you as well a
graphics card like this is going to
allow you to speed up your creative
workflow with more cores
give you more creative freedom with its
16 gigabytes of gpu memory and allow you
to knock out ai-based
tasks with ease and since nvidia and pny
can only send prizes to the us artists
i want to sweeten the pot for my
international artists so for first
second and third place you'll not only
receive one not two
but three limited edition archival photo
prints signed by yours truly
as well as top tier access to my patreon
when it drops very very soon which gives
you guys access to all of my cg assets
3d packs project files and more so
how does one go about winning this
challenge
well i'm gonna judge it off of a few
things
first the idea does your contraption
feel unique
compared to the other ideas does it look
and feel like it would actually function
are you using the individual components
in a creative and interesting way
and does your contraption have a theme
or specific style does it just make you
say whoa that's freaking sweet
next is visual appeal does it look nice
is it lit well and rendered properly
do you have a distinct color palette are
the individual elements of your
contraption placed
in an artistic way i'll be looking at
animation
and clarity as well can i track the ball
and your machine's function with ease
does the animation feel natural and have
a distinct flow
does your ball appear to follow the
proper laws of gravity
and finally this contest will be judged
on your ability to follow the rules that
i previously
listed they're very important to making
a seamless
montage so as fellow creatives and
passionate cg artists
let's learn and grow together but at the
end of the day let's just have some fun
making some sweet 3d contraptions
so get started right now by clicking the
link in the description which
leads to the dynamic machines landing
page where you guys can check specific
rules and guidelines
info on the prizes as well as download
the starter project
files inside which is the template 3d
scene as well as an example render which
you can use to compare
your render to to make sure you are
following the rules very specifically
and also there's a link to my discord
server in the description
and on the landing page where you guys
can share your work and troubleshoot
certain roadblocks
with other like-minded artists to submit
your art i'll be posting a submission
link two weeks into this challenge on
the landing page
and my discord server august 1st 11 59
pm
pst is the deadline i will be live
streaming my process
today at 10 45 am pst
come join me let's hang out let's figure
out what we're going to do together
and i can't wait to see how this turns
out so i'll see you guys soon
peace
[Music]
you